Hi everyone.
Listen, let me run you through our plan
to how we're going to fix the economy
and reduce the cost of living.
It's got five parts to it.
The first is that we are going to make sure we
don't pass costs onto businesses
that lead to higher prices
and therefore
more inflation.
Secondly, we're going to free up our businesses,
get rid of the red tape,
make sure immigration settings are right
so they can actually grow their companies
and do really well.
Thirdly, we've got to go through $137 billion
of government spending,
line item by line item,
to make sure that you,
the taxpayer,
are getting great value from it.
Fourthly, we're going to give you your tax relief
because we think you can spend the money
much better than Grant Roberts and a Chris Hippkins can.
And finally,
we're going to make sure the Reserve Bank is focused
on getting inflation back under 3%.
That's how we fix our economy
to reduce the cost of living.
And that's how we get New Zealand back on track.